le magazine Que Choisir consacre son
mois de février à une enquête sur les
grandes surfaces ou acheter moins cher
1670 établissements visités parmi
lesquels ceux des Yvelines bien sûr
bonsoir Philippe fleuret vous êtes le
responsable de l'antenne de Versailles
et de l'UFC Que Choisir on va parler des
grands enseignements à retenir de cette
enquête tout d'abord peut-être une
première question où est-il moins cher
de faire ses courses est-ce que dans le
département des Yvelines on est favorisé
sur ce plan là déjà par rapport au reste
de la France le département des Yvelines
il se situe dans la moyenne des
départements français ceci dit il y a
des endroits dans les Yvelines où on
peut acheter nettement moins cher que
dans d'autres endroits ça c'est une
réalité alors on va voir ça dans
quelques instants justement on va
préciser comment a été mené cette
enquête du magazine Que Choisir 1670
magasins visités sur les 11000 que
compte l'Hexagone c'était entre le 22
septembre et le 6 octobre 70 produits de
référence le coût moyen de se panier de
77 articles 215 euros et dans le
département des Yvelines il y a 16
hypermarchés au supermarché qui sont en
dessous de 215 tout à fait tout à fait
tout à fait donc on retrouve je dirais
un peu les mêmes tendances que les
années passées parce que nous faisons
cette enquête une fois par an et donc
cette fois-ci encore les hypermarchés
sont dans la fourchette basse
c'est-à-dire là où les prix sont les
moins chers donc toutes les grandes
enseignes donc je peux les citer parce
que elles sont toutes que ça soit voilà
Leclerc Auchan Carrefour donc sont des
hypermarchés j'ai dit bien les
hypermarchés sont parmi les endroits où
on trouve les prix les plus bas parce
que l'enseignement peut-être principal
c'est ça mais c'est presque une évidence
ceci dit pour ceux qui font leurs
courses ils s'en sont forcément rendus
compte dans les hyper les supermarchés
on paye moins cher que dans les petites
supérettes que dans les supérettes ou
les ou les supermarchés oui ça c'est
vrai donc il y a plusieurs raisons à
cela bon parce que bon les frais de
fonctionnement impossible sont un peu
moins chers les masses de produits
achetés sur plus importants donc des
possibilités de négociation plus fortes
sur les prix et quelques établissements
qu'on peut citer le plus mauvais élève
du département alors le plus mauvais
élève du département
casino qui se trouve à Maisons-Laffitte
voilà est le meilleur et le meilleur
c'est le Leclerc ici à côté donc de
Bois-d'Arcy et celui de
carrière-sous-poissy qui s'en sort
plutôt bien donc dans cette enquête
menée par Que Choisir c'est une enquête
au niveau au niveau national et qui est
plutôt intéressant aussi pour voir
l'inflation parce que c'est aussi ça la
différence un petit peu oui tout à fait
alors au cours de l'année 2012 il y a
des prix de certains articles qui ont
augmenté et d'autres qui ont baissé si
on prend la moyenne générale les prix
ils ont été assez raisonnables parce
qu'ils sont documentaires moyenne de
0,8% alors que l'inflation est
supérieure à 1% donc 1,2 exactement
selon l'Insee mais ça dépend ceci dit
des articles et des articles des
articles oui mais là on a quand même un
panel très très important bon c'est vrai
que après selon les semaines il peut y
avoir des semaines avec des promotions
sur certains produits des marques
distributeurs donc ça c'est au
consommateur après de bien regarder ce
qui se passe sur les 77 produits de ce
panier qui a servi de deux références on
trouve de tous les articles de tous
types de l'épicerie des produits
laitiers de la boucherie la poissonnerie
les soins les produits mén tout outil
absolument oui quels sont les articles
qui peut-être qui ont plus augmenté et
d'autres qui ont baissé alors ceux qui
ont le plus augmenter sur un quelques
exemples le café par exemple a augmenté
certains produits
Yoplait par exemple et puis d'autres ont
baissé comme les l'huile d'olive par
exemple ça ça diminué le pastis augmente
par exemple mais ça c'est les taxes
derrière mais comme il est consommé avec
le modération voilà ça doit pas trop se
ressentir sur le budget l'aménage les
ménages dépensent pardon en moyenne en
France 129 euros
et par semaine bien évidemment cette
enquête qui se penche aussi sur les
drives alors ça c'est un système de plus
en plus utilisé ça permet de faire ses
courses via Internet vous allez les
smartphones et on récupère ensuite on se
rend avec son véhicule sa voiture on
récupère la sortie du magasin on vient
directement déposer
quelque chose qui se développe assez
rapidement depuis deux ans on compte
maintenant en France 2001 drive donc
vous avez précisé oui comment on procède
on fait ces on passe sa commande sur
internet et après on prend livraison
donc sur le site
on n'a pas constaté de grosses anomalies
bon il peut arriver que certains
produits soient manquants ça c'est
possible mais dans l'ensemble les prix
sont à peu près identiques d'où une
interrogation les coûts quand même pour
le distributeur sans plus important
c'est un double manipulation
généralement donc nous restons vigilants
pour voir si effectivement il y aura pas
de dérive par la suite c'est pour le
mastod du même prix on imagine pour que
les se soient développés mais ensuite il
faut qu'effectivement ça reste à ce à ce
niveau là puisqu'on parlait d'Internet
de faire ses courses sur Internet il y a
aussi quelque chose qui se développe ce
sont ces comparateurs de prix sur les
smartphones oui est-ce que c'est
véritablement efficace alors
ça permet de d'avoir des tendances si
vous voulez parce que bon il y a deux
essentiellement
un comparateur de prix qui est un peu
adossé à l'enseigne Leclerc donc qui
permet d'avoir une connaissance
en fonction de sa géolocalisation
c'est-à-dire que c'est les magasins
autour de son lieu de résidence et donc
d'avoir des comparaisons bon mais ça
reste objectif même si c'est adossé à
une grande enseigne oui ce don sur le
tube objectif parce que ils peuvent pas
se permettre de tricher malgré tout ils
prennent non non non non c'est assez ça
subjectif et puis il y a une autre une
autre site qui permet lui d'avoir à
partir des prix dans les drives c'est à
des prix qui sont mis en ligne sur
internet donc d'avoir un panel beaucoup
plus important de prix donc vous me
direz peut-être plus objectif mais il y
a aussi un système de coupon pour
inciter les consommateurs donc à acheter
certains produits d'envoyer donc une
petite réserve 22 sur ce côté mais ça
donne une ça donne une idée de la
tendance et pour conclure puisque vous
êtes présent sur ce plateau j'aimerais
aussi qu'on s'intéresse aux orientations
prises par l'UFC pour l'année 2013 le FC
Que Choisir puisque la semaine dernière
le président de votre instance au niveau
national Alain bazo a déclaré vouloir
jouer maintenant un rôle d'intermédiaire
entre consommateur et entreprise afin de
proposer des offres commerciales à des
tarifs plus attractifs c'est à dire que
vous changez un petit peu la façon de
procéder et vous orientations oui si il
s'agit de suivre les besoins des
consommateurs c'est-à-dire que au début
notre action allait surtout sur les
litiges c'est-à-dire c'était les
personnes des consommateurs qui étaient
mécontents qui avaient un litige avec
une enseigne ou un commerçant qui venait
nous voir ça maintenant
selon le fait toujours mais il faut
aller plus loin et il faut il faut
développer les actions de conseil
c'est-à-dire développer des actions de
comparateur des actions de service aussi
donc pour être répandre aux attentes des
consommateurs tout à fait et ce sera une
des priorités pour 2013 donc pour l'UFC
Que Choisir merci Philippe ferait d'être
passé sur ce plateau on va revoir juste
la une du Que Choisir de ce mois de
février ou acheter moins cher c'est la
une de ce dossier voilà pour le magazine
au mois de février tous les résultats à
découvrir en kiosque bien sûr le rappel
des titres à présent les sujets que nous
avons développé ce soir et que vous
pouvez retrouver sur notre site Internet
et bien évidemment commenté sur les
réseaux sociaux et notamment twitter les
titres donc quel choix de rythme
scolaire et c'est cette question que ce
sont posées les parents d'élèves de la
FCPE à l'occasion d'une réunion il se
disent favorable à une application
rapide de la mesure présentée par
Vincent payant la réforme des rythmes
scolaires qui divisent les mairies
également faudra-t-il l'appliquer en
2013 ou en 2014 en septembre bien sûr
les avis divergent dans l'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la principe
principalement les mers attendent d'en
savoir plus le nouveau bâtiment abritant
le café de la plage à un Maurepas ainsi
que la boutique infogènes inaugurée le
bâtiment de 900 mètres carrés
accueillera de ça au lieu d'une
auparavant coût des travaux environ 3
millions d'euros
et puis le metteur en scène Antoine
jeans vous le voyez revient au théâtre
de 50 ans en Yvelines pour présenter une
nouvelle création qui fait écho à sa
trilogie rixaga il offre donc une suite
à son personnage phare Watan c'est la
fin du 7 8 pour ce 30 janvier
rendez-vous demain 18h pour une nouvelle
édition en direct nous parlerons
notamment cuisine puisque je vous
rappelle que Thibault Ruggieri le
Français a décroché là première place au
Bocuse d'Or c'était il y a quelques
instants à Lyon la compétition s'est
déroulée sur deux jours le palmarès elle
vient tout juste d'être dévoilée et
c'est le chef le sous-chef du la
création salée dans l'établissement Le
Nôtre à Plaisir dans les Yvelines nous
le recevons prochainement sur ce plateau
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée à
demain